you guys know fear is more contagious
than a virus
you hang around with a bunch of people
who are terrified you can not keep from
becoming terrified you know what's as
contagious as fear hope hanging around
with a bunch of people that are hopeful
it's not a Pollyanna it's not a stick
your head in the sand and ignore the
facts that's not the point but the point
is I'm really having my perspective
correct and I know that by this time
next year probably by September the vast
majority of this and the effects of it
are going to be a distant memory I'm all
old I've seen a bunch of the stuff that
is going to bring into the world come
and go and it just didn't work out for
him it has been it's been something
trying to bring it into this world for a
long time and hadn't worked out so far I
don't think this world is gonna end
until God decides it's going to end yeah
so just remember if you back up if you
pan back a little bit it sure is easier
to keep calmer and really watch what
your inputs are what's your input
my friend Zig Ziglar used to say I read
the Bible in the newspaper every morning
and that way I can tell what both sides
are doing so I mean you need to have the
input and assume you don't know what a
news paper is look it up it's in
Wikipedia but um the remember your dad's
shaking it out and getting it getting it
right yeah to be able to read it a long
time ago wasn't newspapers hadn't been
thick enough to shake out in a long time
but anyway yeah it's gonna be okay
perspective if you pan back and you go
look at all the other disasters that
we're going to bring an end of the stock
market bring it into your career bring
it into your life as you know it and
they just didn't as disasters go that
generally are fairly disappointing and
so you're gonna be okay okay I know some
of your going through some stuff man
that's why we're here we're here to help
you I am NOT overlooking that I am NOT
looking down on that I'm not any of
those things a lot I've got some extra
stress
now that's very real you know I'm
responsible for thousand people in this
building we're washing everything in
here this place looks like one big swath
of hand sanitizer the whole place smells
like hand sanitizers crazy we've wiped
everything down to CDC standards and oh
my god on and on oh no no no no no no
but you know hey it's a smart thing to
do it's the right thing to do
you know you don't want you want to
create a situation where people get sick
but on the other hand I'm not going to
sit in my home and suck my thumb and be
afraid I'm not gonna live in fear fear
is contagious you guys be careful with
it
it's it's what it brings wisdom because
it doesn't let you play in the traffic
and doesn't let you do something dumb
that brings harm to you and I don't want
you to do that either but um the truth
but the truth is is that hope is
contagious too so and hope really I hope
deferred hope put off makes the heart
sick but when desire comes it is the
tree of life and God says that he didn't
come the yeah he's got a plan for you
and it's not to bring harm to you but to
give you hope hope is a real thing and
you need to just stop and breathe that
in have enough fear to be wise but not
to be paralyzed and unwise and
overreaching and overreacting when you
overreact you double the cause of the
car wreck